for the first time in 75 years more
Mexican immigrants are leaving the u.s.
than coming in from 2009 to 2014 about 1
million Mexicans and their families
including their american-born children
left the u.s. from Mexico during that
same period only eight hundred and
seventy thousand went the other way in
the last 35 years 16 million Mexicans
have immigrated to the u.s. they've
migrated here in search of work safety
and to be with family what has been the
largest wave of immigrants to the u.s.
from a single country might now be over
why is it happening
the main reason people are going back is
family sixty-one percent say they
returned to join or to start a family
14 percent had been deported and six
percent said they went back for jobs
many Mexican immigrants work in
industries that have been hit hard by
the u.s. recession including
construction hospitality and agriculture
and the fact that Mexico's population is
aging makes the job market less
competitive there from 1995 to 2000 the
net migration from Mexico to the US was
over two million much of that thanks to
Mexico's economic crisis when the value
of the peso crashed and thanks to the
North American Free Trade Agreement that
flooded the country with American
imports and hurt local industry but
between 2005 and 2010 that number fell
meaning more people were going back to
Mexico than coming into the US and from
2009 to 2014 the number fell even more
that could have something to do with the
fact that Obama has deported more
immigrants than any other US president
more than two million people and
increased border security has also made
crossing both more expensive and more
dangerous according to the u.s. Border
Patrol over 4100 people have died
crossing the border since 2005 all this
has deterred Mexicans from even
considering immigrating illegally given
the risks and while immigration from
Mexico has gone down immigration from
China and India has gone up so if the so
called flood of Mexican immigrants into
the u.s. is declining then is the age of
scapegoating Mexicans over